while u.s agent is a significant player
in the comic book universe
he's not a household name among
mainstream marvel fans
and that's why we're going to run down
some of his weirdest and wildest stories
here's the untold truth of marvel's u.s
agent
in captain america number 323 readers
are introduced to super patriot
the original super heroic identity of us
agent
as super patriot john walker seems like
the exact opposite of the captain
america that readers know
while cap was often thoughtful and aware
of the responsibility of his uniform
super patriot ignores an old lady being
mugged because the crime isn't glitzy
enough for him to bother to stop it
he's first introduced trash talking cap
and urging the american people to focus
their patriotic energy on him
as you might expect cap's not thrilled
about the upstart new hero but he's
willing to let super patriot
express his first amendment rights until
he finds out that super patriot and his
cronies are manufacturing events to make
themselves look better
after super patriot and his buckies
short for bold urban commandos
cause enough trouble for cap steve
rogers and john walker finally face off
somewhat surprisingly walker's not all
bluster he's got super strength and
enough fight training that he actually
battles cap to a draw
the fight only ends when bruce
springsteen shows up causing walker to
choose listening to the boss
rather than beating up on captain
america as the old saying goes
if you want to be the man you gotta beat
the man you just don't know when to give
up do you
do this all day captain america has to
deal with
a lot of stuff like hydra or the winter
soldier but
as it turns out he's got even bigger
problems
the man owes back taxes to the u.s
government combined with the fact that
his superhero identity powers and
unbreakable shield are all the property
of the federal government
a federal council called the commission
tells the hero that he's no longer
able to keep operating as an independent
entity the commission offers him a
choice
work under their purview or give up
being captain america
steve walks out on them choosing to
adopt a black costume and the moniker of
the captain
in order to keep his independence in
captain america number 333
the commission taps super patriot to
replace cap training him to fight
smarter and work harder
one of walker's buckies lamar hoskins
gets the opportunity to join the new
campus's partner
while the other two are left on their
lonesome to become vaguely
self-interested super villains called
left winger and right winger walker's
willing to prove that he's ready for the
big time but he's not quite the
pure-hearted patriot that his
predecessor was
unlike the original cap walker's got
some serious anger issues stemming from
a brother who died in vietnam
and his time getting experimented on by
the power broker
the man who gave walker hoskins and the
other buckies their super strength
heavy is the head that wears captain
america's little head wings
almost immediately after taking on the
role of captain america walker runs into
trouble
his former pals left winger and right
winger reveal his secret identity to the
world in captain america number 341
four issues later his parents are killed
by the watchdogs
a militant group of domestic super
terrorists obsessed with keeping america
free of
filth walker's response is to kill a
bunch of the watch dogs and then hunt
down left winger and right winger to
[ __ ] them in a massive oil tanker
explosion
that's not exactly acceptable behavior
for a captain america
but the commission keeps him on anyway
and there's good reason for that
perennial thorn in the original cap side
the red skull
engineered the entire string of events
manipulating the commission
walker and even the watchdogs all in
order to drag
cap's good name through the mud it all
comes to a head in captain america
number 350 when the captain and walker
team up to take down the red skull
when the dust settles walker is
impressed with the original cap's
convictions and skill
when the commission begs rogers to take
back the suit he refuses
but walker convinces him to return
admitting that the job was harder than
he thought it would be
captain america number 351 sees walker
return
the captain america's suit and shield to
rogers during a press event but the
celebration is cut short when walker is
brutally shot by a watchdog
who is soon killed himself by the
homicidal vigilante scourge
lamar hoskins walker's former partner
now operating under the moniker battle
star
finds something suspicious about the
series of events eventually discovering
that the watchdog who murdered walker
wasn't a real member of the organization
instead he was a government agent who
faked walker's death to give the former
captain america time to undergo memory
implants
plastic surgery and vocal lessons in
order to begin a new identity as jack
daniels aka
us agent however it's not quite a
completely fresh start
as his new outfit looks just like steve
rogers
the captain suit plus he still got a
vibranium replica shield
the commission puts u.s agent to work as
their man on the inside for the west
coast avengers
a group of also rans operating out of
los angeles instead of new york
while on the team u.s agent doesn't
exactly make
friends but he still joins the team in
fighting master pandemonium
a former movie executive who made a deal
with the devil and stole the scarlet
witch's imaginary babies to use as his
arms in hell
that's not exactly the type of threat
that a super strong patriot is equipped
to handle
around this time u.s agent's old friend
battlestar shows up to restore his
memories and
remind him that he's not just a
government stooge since that also means
remembering that his parents are dead
it's a bit of a mixed blessing for john
jack
it might seem like us agent only battles
against captain america's arch enemies
alongside cap's old friends
while never having any adventures of his
own but that's not exactly true
in the us agent miniseries john walker
battles against scourge
the vigilante that shot the man who
pretended to shoot walker way back in
captain america number 351
yeah we know it's kind of confusing but
it gets crazier
as it turns out the scourge isn't the
same guy as the one before
instead scourge is an identity offered
up to basically anyone who wants it
each scourge is given the same training
information
and resources to go around and murder
criminals kind of like
the punisher however when the newest
scourge priscilla lions
is tasked with gunning down a bad guy
she suddenly decides she can't do it as
it seems the criminal has genuinely
reformed
of course the rest of the scourge aren't
pleased about this so lions begs u.s
agent to help her stay alive but after
they team up to find the source of the
scourge organization
u.s agent is captured drugged and
eventually released by the scourge
trainer
bloodstain bloodstain then reveals that
he's actually mike walker
john's brother who is supposedly killed
in vietnam but that ends up being a mind
game
to confuse u.s agent i missed out on the
whole thing to be honest with you i was
confused by it i'm very confused by the
i was very confused by the whole thing
to be if i'm being honest
ultimately walker finds the true
mastermind behind scourge a decrepit old
man
who used to be the old marvel hero the
angel not to be confused with the x-men
of the same name
bloodstain dies in the fight and u.s
agent leaves the old man trapped and
helpless on the lawn of his mansion
they saved nothing lasts forever and
that
includes the west coast avengers the
team comes to an end in west coast
avengers number 102
which finds the main avengers team
criticizing and ultimately firing
everyone in the spin-off group
u.s agent takes the team's dissolution
hard
throwing his shield and costume into the
hudson river luckily for him it doesn't
take long for most of the west coast
avengers to reform into a new group
created by iron man
a team called force works u.s agent
keeps his code name
but he finally dons a costume that
wasn't formally worn by captain america
unfortunately it's terrible it does come
with some new weapons though
to replace the vibranium shield he threw
into the hudson u.s agent is given
photon gauntlets that can create a laser
shield and shoot laser blasts
together with scarlet witch iron man
wonder man
spider woman and an interdimensional
alien named
century force works battles against a
bunch of aliens
and dream monsters proving that no idea
or
team name was too crazy to publish in
the 90s
for someone who's been around the marvel
universe for as long as john walker has
he doesn't have the best track record
for keeping friends
that's probably because any time a
former pal of his does
anything even remotely questionable
walker is the first one showing up to
berate them and send them to prison
that's certainly the case when hawkeye
takes over the thunderbolts a team of
former super villains who want to start
living on the right side of the law
people aren't exactly thrilled that
hawkeye himself a former criminal
and a bunch of former supervillains are
hanging out in colorado
their presence leads walker to become
the leader of the jury
a corporate owned superhero team that
transitions over from
symbiote hunting and bothering venom to
taking down the thunderbolts
since the thunderbolts are the team with
their name on the comet cover they
handily trounce the jury
eventually sending us agent bouncing
back around the marvel universe to look
for a new job
john walker pops up again during
marvel's event comic maximum security
which sees the former super patriot
becoming a superhuman bounty hunter
tracking down super villain bail jumpers
under the organization
stars the job also comes with a new
costume which changes the captain
america-esque outfit into a cross
between a riot cop
and judge dredd complete with an
electrically charged riot baton and
another photon shield
walker's new career is complicated
somewhat by the revelation that earth
itself
has become an interplanetary prison for
the worst criminals in the galaxy that
situation is eventually resolved but
walker sticks around
continuing to hunt down super criminals
while trying to prove himself as
something more than just a captain
america copy
considering how that led to a
three-issue mini-series
followed by a brief stint where he wears
a fake captain america costume in order
to be a part of the new invaders an
updated version of the world war ii team
of captain america
namor bucky and the original human torch
his efforts to get away from the steve
rogers comparisons haven't worked out
that well
that is america's ass
during the civil war comic event john
walker works for tony stark on the side
of the government registration for
superpowered beings
one side effect of registration is that
villains begin fleeing across the border
to canada
in order to escape stark's iron grip
stark assigns walker to head up the new
omega flight program
which is necessary given that alpha
flight has been killed by a mutant named
michael pointer who was possessed by
aliens in a bid to take over earth
walker initially refuses the assignment
but changes his mind after getting
thrown off a building by
the purple man walker's new team
consists of julia
arachne carpenter talisman sasquatch
beta ray bill and weapon omega aka
michael pointer talisman is outraged
that the man who killed her father is on
the team
but poynter proves himself in a battle
against a demon-powered
wrecking crew walker remains his usual
obnoxious self in leading the team but
the job seems to agree with him
as always though it doesn't last long
john walker has spent most of his career
trying to differentiate himself from
steve rogers so
here's the good news u.s agent
eventually does find a way to
distinguish himself from captain america
but
here's the bad news it comes with him
getting his arm and leg cut off by the
super villain
nuke during siege an event comic that
sees norman osborn declaring war on
asgard
walker's given the option of high-tech
prosthetics that would make luke
skywalker envious but he accepts his
missing limbs and ultimately retires
from active duty
in the interim he becomes the warden of
the supervillain prison
the raft assisting luke cage in the
formation of a new team of thunderbolts
which
uses more traditional super villains as
a kind of
probationary superhero team for
extremely dangerous missions
well with some kind of suicide squad
kind of that group eventually gives way
to the dark avengers a team of villains
pretending to be their super heroic
rivals
while on a mission walker and the dark
avengers are teleported into an
alternate reality where
after being mistaken for that reality's
john walker us agent gets his limbs
restored
after making it back to their home
reality the team bounds to stick
together through thick and thin
which doesn't really last beyond that
final issue
regardless of what team he's on or what
the status quo of the marvel universe
might be
u.s agent is inextricably tied to
captain america
that's to be expected when even his
post-captain america identity still has
an identical shield
and cap's unused costume but as it turns
out
that connection is consistent even when
it's not steve rogers wearing the stars
and stripes
when sam wilson the falcon takes over
for captain america after steve is
turned into an old man by a supervillain
u.s agent steps in to convince sam to
give up the shield
despite his lack of super strength the
new captain america is able to take down
the us
agent by dumping him into a pitch black
tunnel and wailing on him until walker
is out for the count
still as with any hero vs hero conflict
there's a deeper conspiracy going on
u.s agent wasn't just encouraged to
attack sam wilson because a gung-ho
talk show radio host told him to as it
turns out steve rogers actually put him
up to it because of some complicated
shenanigans involving the red skull the
cosmic cube
and a massively controversial retcon
that saw steve become
a secret hydra loyalist as with most
comic story lines it eventually gets
reverted back into the normal status quo
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one